all right connecticut's not playing
football this year they're head coaches
randy yetzel who uh
joins us an independent school as of
this year
uh coach thanks for joining us when the
did the department decide on this
that you're not going to have football
this year well we've
uh been going through this process dan
since really july the 1st
you know once our kids came back to
campus you know when we first started
the uh
the testing process where our young men
had to test uh
take a test for the covid and uh be
negative before they could take a uh
a physical and then the ncaa allowed us
to have
uh some voluntary workouts and then
starting july 12th we were allowed to
have
uh workouts where um you know we could
have eight hours of uh
lifting and conditioning uh or six hours
lifting conditioning in meetings
and then uh starting um
july 22nd then we were able to get into
20 hours per week where we could do
walk-throughs and then also have
virtual meetings uh and do that so as we
were going through this whole process
there were situations that arose um
with our young people we we still
haven't had a young man test positive
yet
so that that is really a good thing the
the procedures and protocols that
our university put into place has been
very good
but what had happened through this whole
process is uh
we had three young men who uh had
came down with symptoms you know they
got up in the morning and we have to
fill out a nap to say
you know do you have these symptoms
before you can even get into the
building
and we had those young men who had to be
isolated
three of them and in july the 10th july
the 17th and then july
25th and with those young men having no
symptoms then you have to do the contact
tracing
so when you do the contact tracing now
you're incorporating
in our first one there were seven other
young men the second one there was three
and then this last one was nine
so we've had 22 young men that we've
there's been an average of 10 days in
terms of getting a test back
and then when you take into the
consideration that uh when you go on the
field there are certain things you can
and cannot do
social distancing um yesterday was
supposed to be our first practice
we went out on the field but we weren't
able we weren't able to use helmets
we weren't able to have shields where
guys could go block we couldn't
get up and play press coverage how are
we going to pull this off coach
how is college football going to happen
you're a connecticut if you were still
at maryland
would you be playing football would your
would you have a team
this year take the field no and i and i
said that yesterday
in the press conference if i was a if i
was a head coach and i was at a power
five conference whether it's the big ten
or the acc
you know i would go to my administration
and i would sit down with our players
and i would say we can't play football
and that's exactly what i did
i was on the field as all this was going
on in july i called my athletic director
and told him i said there's no way we
can do this with all the things that we
have to go through
and and that's even before you get into
the game because i don't think these
kids are going to be
could be properly prepared and
conditioned to go in and play a game i
think you're going to see a lot of
injuries
because kids aren't prepared to go in
but like i said
if i was in the big ten the acc i would
be saying the same thing
and doing the same thing you know money
is not the
the object here you know schedule is not
the object
as you go through this we can't even use
our locker room dan
you know our kids can't even go in the
locker room we're using sick we have 16
people in the weight room
lifting at one time we can't we couldn't
go in and use our training room
uh the way it needed to be so you could
have prevention of injuries where guys
we can only get two guys in our
huge um cold tubs those things
nobody can still tell me and you know we
had some people calling us and
with the games and then you know nobody
can still tell me how you're going to do
game day
you know are you going to have to dress
at the hotel bus to the stadium
are you going to have to uh how do you
get a social distance the ncaa is
putting you
social distance on the sideline from the
20 to 20 kids have to wear masks if
they're not in the game
but now before the game it's going to be
okay to be in the locker room
or it's going to be okay at half time to
go in there then after the game
you know right now here at uconn we were
in a bubble
but in eight days we got eight thousand
students coming back
our bubble was gone everybody else's
bubble was gone are coaches in denial
randy um
i i just think there's people afraid to
make decisions dan
people in leadership positions are
afraid to make decisions
and they're kicking the can down the
road and they're trying to say
okay we're going to try to do everything
that we can knowing
in the back of their mind it's probably
not going to happen and they're going to
cancel the season
and that's why i give our players credit
because our players came to me
and we were talking they said coach
there's no way we can have a season
and i concurred with them so we sat down
on friday this past friday myself
our leadership council 12 young men our
athletic director
david benedict dr cassiero our team
physician our trainer
and i told our guys you express your
concerns
to um to david and to doc cassiero and
bob
and they did they want to play dan
there's no doubt about that
they want to play it's not that they
don't want to play but
they just are very concerned about their
safety
and the lack of answers that people can
have because of this virus because it's
new and people don't know
and they just didn't think the risk was
worse worth the reward
he's randy edsel the yukon head football
coach
you had games against indiana and
illinois so big ten was going conference
only
ole miss they were going to go
conference only north carolina virginia
conference only
how are you going to have a schedule if
you decided to play how are you going to
fill in
those uh those weekends well there were
people that were calling us
but we also have in this state dan we
have a travel ban
i know that and connecticut has done a
great job with this virus
their numbers are way down you know
governor lamont has done a great job
okay so if we went to play the only two
states
only two games that on we had on our
schedule was umass
and uh uh army that we've could have
played because all those other teams
that we were gonna play
they were in states where there was a
travel ban there was people that we
could have played we had people calling
us
people were calling david coaches were
calling me
and um but in terms of the protocols
and everything else you know it wasn't
but it wasn't so much that dan
it was more so because our players
didn't feel
safe and the one thing that i think has
to happen and i
that i'm glad we made the decision and
our young people had
a saying a big say in it okay and that's
the thing to me that's missing
i don't think these players the people
who are playing the game
first and foremost don't have a say in
what's going on
no i applaud you with that coach because
we've seen this at other
coaches and other situations where hey
you know we value our student athletes
until they're not
on the same page with you we saw this
with washington state
hey uh we're all in it together wait
you're not
you don't agree with me as the coach
well then we want you off the team
i'm glad that you're listening to them
because they don't have a singular voice
who represents them
and that's what worries me the most
about all of this those kids
are going to play they don't want to
lose their scholarships but
i think there are a lot of coaches in
denial right now have you heard from
other coaches since your decision
whether you want to
make their names known nationally here i
i'm not
i'm not i'm not going to name names then
but
uh uh yes i have gotten responses from
coaches and say
and have said thanks for speaking up and
glad you had the guts to do what you've
done
and and i think you know again all you
got to do dan and this is a whole
problem
okay you know and i said this
a couple days ago put the put the pluses
put the minuses down
there's only one plus money yeah it's
the only plus
is money and you go down to minuses and
there's much more
i think there's a lot of i think there's
a lot of coaches
there's a lot of players that don't want
to have the season
my assistant coaches have gotten calls
from people i've gotten calls from
people
okay uh i know our players appreciate
them having a word because they know
other people
and they say coach we're glad we had a
say because those people don't have a
say somewhere else
and that's that's what really bothers me
the most
is you know don't talk about the health
and welfare of the student athlete
if you're not going to go and listen to
them and engage them in the conversation
because as i've said i'm not playing the
game
david benedict's not playing the game
our board of trustees doesn't play in
the game
our president isn't playing the game
those are the guys and you know what all
you got to do is take a look at
you know in the nfl the nfl
has has a players union they have a
players association
well guess what they were going to put
them out there no the players
association spoke up
and they ended up getting things changed
so those guys could go in and feel safe
and then they also
if they didn't want to play they could
opt out and there was options for them
there
in the college game like i said
everybody talks about that
but you're right nobody backs it up
everybody walks away from it when it's
when push comes to shove well coach
thanks for joining us
uh appreciate your time as always and uh
i don't know what you do over the next
five months
but uh well we have a plan you know the
thing is i'm meeting this afternoon with
our uh
leadership council and we're going to
put the plan together and what we're
going to do we're going to work to get
bigger faster stronger
we're going to go on the field and do
work but again our players are going to
have a say in that in terms of what we
do along with our strength coach
and you know we're going to gear
ourselves to 2021
and again the spring was never an option
because to me
you talk about the health and welfare
and safety of a student athlete
how could you go and play games all the
way up to may and may and then come back
and play another scheme
yeah yeah not possible coach thank you
we appreciate your time
okay dan appreciate it that's uh randy
edsel he's the head coach
at connecticut